from the daily caller twitter suspends
former treasury official after he
compared brian stalter to the [ __ ] from
pulp fiction
this is uh not newsworthy
but uh considering you know for those
are just tuning in like or didn't watch
the last segments we were talking very
very seriously about war and gun rights
and i was like and now we need to slam
into a brick wall of nonsense to kind of
calm down and have a good laugh
at the expense of others
yeah so uh the reason i'm the reason i'm
starting with this and uh we're gonna be
ragging on brian selter it's not because
somebody compared him to the [ __ ] from
pulp fiction but more so because he is
being slammed quote this is how state tv
functions glenn greenwald rips cnn's
brian stelter for fawning over white
house's gensake in one of the most
sycophantic interviews a state of a
state official you'll ever see
now this is funny we're going to read
the [ __ ] story but i want to just stress
the point that brian scott is the guy
who completely
who routinely ragged on fox as the state
propaganda it's the propaganda arm of
the state this is what state tv looks
like and then give him the opportunity
and he just gives i wouldn't even call
it a softball interview it was a wiffle
ball interview he was he was lightly
tossing wiffle balls to jenseki who then
hit him straight out of the park well
here's what happened on the daily caller
they say
internet accountability project founder
mike davis and former treasury official
will upton were temporarily suspended
from twitter for comparing cnn anchor
brian stelter to the character [ __ ] from
the movie pulp fiction twitter first
suspended update on sunday night after
he made a post that mocked the anchor
stelter has asked
stelter had asked press secretary
gensecki what she believed the media
doesn't accurately cover about the biden
administration
fun fact brian stelter is the
is the [ __ ] from pulp fiction hubtin's
initial tweet read which was followed up
by a jiff of the character from 1989
from the 1994 film oh so they restored
it
wonderful
upton was suspended shortly after
posting the tweet but had his account
unsuspended a few hours later after
successfully appealing the suspension
the federalist reported upton tweeted
that he simply pointed out that
comparing a public figure to a fictional
movie character does not violate the
terms of service saying correct lol this
tweet got me temporarily suspended from
twitter i appealed in one i simply
pointed out that comparing a public
figure to a fictional movie character
does not violate their terms of service
shortly after upton was unsuspended
davis was then temporarily suspended
from twitter for defending upton's post
according to the federalist siding that
he had violated rules against hateful
conduct on the site
you really put big tech critic w upton
in a twitter jail for comparing brian
silver to the [ __ ] and pulp fiction i'd
be very upset if i were the [ __ ] as well
bravo good sir now let's talk about uh
not what we're getting look i i point
this out you know glenn greenwald tears
into cnn but take a look at what's
happening here you see the story nigeria
suspends twitter after twitter suspends
its president
i'm conflicted on this one
just take a look at how
our media operates we got major breaking
news censored in this country the hunter
biden story
many people were polled uh this was a
recipe and paul many many people it was
the most people everyone agrees now a
lot of people were polled and it turns
out around six percent of people said
that had been known about hunter biden
they would not have supported joe biden
which would have been more than enough
for trump to uh take many of the states
he would have needed to win
but uh
twitter facebook youtube they collude
they ban people they do just enough to
make sure milk toast channels like this
one survive but then get rid of anybody
who's posting anything too edgy or too
controversial and they suppress it and
they shut it down
nigeria
struck back
they blocked twitter
they say
the uh the country announced the move
two days after the platform temporarily
froze the nigerian president's official
account on wednesday for allegedly
violating its abusive behavior policy
quote the federal government has
suspended indefinitely the operations of
the microblogging and social networking
service twitter in nigeria a news
release from the nigerian minister of
information and culture alhaji lai
mohammed's office stated so you can see
they announced it in a friday state
announcing the move muhammad cited the
persistent use of the platform for
activities that are capable of
undermining nigeria's corporate
existence
as a reason for the decision according
to the press release the nigerian
government did not provide more details
on how it will carry out the suspension
of tech giant's operations in the
country or on the activities muhammad
mentioned in a statement an aide at the
ministry told reuters wait and see how
things will turn out i don't know how i
feel about this right so again the gist
of the story twitter has suspended
twitter uh is suspended in nigeria after
suspending the president
i don't know i feel about that but i
kind of think it's an important move um
again i'm not sure i'd have to think
through it maybe have some arguments and
hear some some some people what they
think the criticism i suppose is a
government shutting down social media
that sounds bad what if people are
rightly criticizing that that leader as
authoritarian or what if he's a
desperate what if they're sharing real
information trying to challenge what if
it's like you criticize kamala harris
and then she uses the the government to
shut down social media because
they don't like what's happening the
difference here though is that nigeria
blocked twitter because twitter was
interfering with its politics
and that's really really bad so it's
kind of inverted if there's a politician
saying and doing nasty things and we use
social media call them out that's power
to people
if twitter bans those people it's a
problem that's what twitter is doing
conservatives call out malfeasance from
democrats and get banned for doing so we
just read you criticize a cnn anchor and
they suspend you that's insane but what
happens
when twitter is interfering with your
politics like they were here what
happens then when the government says
we're not going to allow twitter to
operate because it's interfering in the
political system
this is different i don't know ian you
you actually have experience moderating
so i'm curious what you think
well with minds was where i moderated at
our terms of service were the us
constitution and specifically
connecticut law where the corporation
was formed so if someone didn't violate
the u.s constitution u.s law uh they
wouldn't get banned off the site um
what's your thoughts on this i mean look
i don't know what did he get banned for
he i don't know he tweeted something
offensive so twitter suspends him if he
violates terms of service then the the
company has a right to ban him but
that legally but i mean it really speaks
it like how how much more powerful these
corporations are than the national
governments you mean the other way
around i think the corporations has more
power and influence than the government
if they want to not necessarily they
don't have a military but they could
definitely hire you know blackwater or
some sort of like mercenary guard if
they wanted twitter could they're not
called it i think blackwater changed
their name now seven times yeah yeah the
bad press i i don't know what do you
think mr sheamus
nigeria banned twitter because twitter
was interfering in their politics i mean
nigeria oh man there was a great someone
made a meme um
about this i don't think it was nigeria
was another country but twitter was
banned there and someone's response was
well you know what nigeria acts as a
private country twitter can make their
own that's right
so i i have to give credit words to i
won't try to pass it off as my own joke
but yeah um i'm not sure i guess i don't
have that strong of an opinion on this
one i think that nigeria can do what
nigeria wants to do if they want to ban
twitter that's what if it's one that's
i'm not going to say they've like
violated some international law so we
should go after them that as a nation
they don't have an obligation to allow
twitter to offer their service in their
country
what if donald trump was like my tweets
have been censored so we are formally
shutting down twitter yeah
would have been interesting yeah i don't
know i'm curious how that would have
played out if he can even have
accomplished something like that given
he was going to be out of office soon i
mean the biden administration would
surely overturn something like that
immediately it is interesting because
it's an american company operating in
america the government doesn't have the
power to do so but for nigeria it's a
foreign corporation operating in their
borders they very well could just be
like
so twitter's learning that some
countries aren't going to put up with
their nonsense oh poor twitter i think
it's the same i feel so bad for that
with the florida law that they're
talking about desantis was going to pass
that if they
you know ban if twitter banned some
people in florida but florida's like hey
you can't do that the twitter would just
get banned out of florida as well like
they just did out of nigeria interesting
or blocked their own activity out of
florida all i know is for a nation to
say that they don't want a foreign
corporation to limit
their leaders ability to leaders
abilities to communicate with their
citizens is not a bad thing that just
seems completely reasonable thing is at
what point is that considered a foreign
corporation anymore like all
corporations are foreign i don't care
where their headquarters is right i mean
they're they're hiding money overseas
they're putting their headquarters in
like ireland and other countries to get
away from taxes maybe some of it's in
nigeria you know maybe they made a deal
with one of those princes
they're going to start putting
corporations in space stations
oh we're not subject to anybody's laws
you can't do anything about it dude
there was this hilarious i was reading
about this um
there was this plan
from some libertarian i would imagine to
build this gigantic boat that would just
be in international waters at all time
making this huge route around the world
and
it was it was for the ultra wealthy for
them to run their businesses so that
they wouldn't have to pay an income tax
anywhere
and what you said just reminded me of
that like imagine at some point they're
going to have these space stations maybe
that's what elon's trying to do he just
wants to go tomorrow so you can be like
look i'm not in america i'm not picking
there's just like one guy
in a in a 10 by 10 space station
and it's just like it's their address is
one space way to see and he lives there
getting paid a lot of money he can't
spend
bezos is retiring as ceo and he's going
to be on the first mission he's retiring
blue origin yeah and he's going to be on
the first man space mission on his new
rocket with his brother they're going to
be on what do you mean on the first day
they're going into space i think it's
blue origin is the name of his car oh
the first man they're planning in june i
think it is uh the first manned
mission into space and he's going to be
on the on the rocket with his brother
wow i'm just waiting for something
interesting to happen you know it's like
every day i wake up and i look at the
news and i'm like
it's kind of the same thing yeah it's
just boring inflation all it is is
reruns
yeah no you gotta go inside if you want
to find the next step of engagement in
this reality i agree we should go into
meditation but not with drugs
yeah breathing apparently breathing can
get you there yeah you know uh certain
types of type of psychedelic trances and
like obviously diet but breathing if you
do different breathing exercises
that's where the excitement lies in
reality my friends you know we've been
in this period for a couple decades
where it's been extremely routine
you know our conflicts have been it's
been so nice
it's been so good
that the crisis we've faced has been
rich people ripping off poor people yeah
it's by design man they placated us they
made
ta marijuana illegal they made lsd
illegal they made psilocybin illegal
they made empty illegal and they're
trying to suppress people they feed them
all the sugar and they keep them like
they have been doing that the rich
people have been taking advantage of the
masses hold on i think if they really
wanted to
lull people into a sleep they'd allow
them to do the drugs no it's the other
way around it's too dangerous for the
status quo
for themselves then why do you think
they're legalizing them all then
it's just you can't fight the tide at
some point the people in the
democratization of power overcomes
tyranny at least that's what it seems
like happens thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you